[Musica]
buonasera già mi sento in colpa di
rubarvi l'ultimo pomeriggio di bel tempo
per domani il tempo cambia se avete la
giornata vede di 25 ore e farabrutto
quindi ho visto rubando del tempo
prezioso
fra l'altro il ted impone di essere
divertenti emozionanti e memorabili sono
lambiccata al cervello per trovare il
modo per risultare per non farli sentire
sprecato questo pomeriggio è divertente
per andare sul sicuro mi metto questo
naso così abbiamo risolto il problema
emozionanti
vi farò arrabbiare perché parlerò di un
concetto che fa veramente a girare le
scatole a tutti proprio una è una cosa
tutti canta il politicamente corretto fa
incavolare la destra e la sinistra fa
incavolare me che sono un umorista un
autrice di satira e mi mette mi mette
veramente nei guai e adesso proverò
essere memorabile ma ho già dei problemi
perché penso per farvi un esempio di
politicamente scorretto qua su due piedi
cosa mi posso inventare e l'unica cosa
che mi viene in mente la più
politicamente scorretta cioè la più
rispettosa delle minoranze di un gruppo
in qualche modo discriminato e salutarvi
dicendovi buonasera a tutti e dove sta
il politicamente scorretto
siete un pubblico misto ci sono donne ci
sono uomini poi se ci sono anche persone
che non hanno ancora deciso cosa essere
ma io per la grammatica devo chiamarvi
tutti tutti prevale il plurale maschile
e nel plurale visto prevale maschile era
così in latino è così in tutte in tutte
le lingue romanze io ho per dire ho tre
figlie e un figlio
devo dire che ho quattro figli poi
dicono che cambiare sesso è una cosa
lunga no un processo lungo
dal punto di vista la grammatica è in
questione poi veramente solo di un
plurale ma è una beffa fa molto
arrabbiare una regola che quando la
impari a scuola da bambina soprattutto
ti ti ti ti ferisce e questo non succede
solo a me problema abbastanza discusso
in francia ci stanno facendo proprio
degli sforzi per rendere il linguaggio
più esclusivo e succedono sfracelli e io
credo che il fatto che le bambine
crescano con l'idea che nel gruppo
scompaiono e anche se sono la pre la
maggioranza e femminile un solo maschio
basta a cambiare genere a tutto il
gruppo secondo e questa è una cosa che
modella il cervello delle ragazze dice
uno le rende meno meno forti nel
pubblico quando si tratta di prendere
parola o o anche di fare politica però
la grammatica e stanno già oggi una
grammatica prevaricante costruita dai
maschi però la nostra grammatica a e
ambigua imprevedibile perché non so
avete presente la nota polemica portata
avanti da alla boldrini si dice sindaco
sindaca avvocata hanno un avvocatessa
ecco la nostra lingua da questo punto di
vista è altamente inclusiva nel
vocabolario perfettamente corretto dire
sindaco come si dice il femminile di
gatto gatta non gat essa il fulmine del
sindaco è sindaca ed un sindachessa
avvocata è un participio passato quindi
si può declinare al maschile al
femminile soldata
anche magari qualche qualche problema si
può avere con termini come dottore i fan
della serie dell'ultima serie
dell'ultima stagione della serie doctor
who
la traduzione in italiano avranno dei
problemi perché l'ultimo doctor who e
una donna e come la chiami dottoressa la
chiami dotto dottore al maschile per i
fan del telefilm che magari si chiedono
che fine ha fatto
modern family che la meravigliosa sitcom
americana su una famiglia allargata con
la coppia gay con personaggi di altre
etnie la la moglie messicana la bambina
vieta vita è finita perché non è più una
modern family una famiglia rabbia
allagata nella negli stati uniti è una
famiglia normale quindi si può dire che
la realtà è quello che accade mentre non
ci accapigliamo su politicamente
corretto
forse però per chiedere lumi sul
femminile dei dei nomi bisognerebbe
consultare l'accademia della crusca che
ha una storia molto interessante che
c'entra col nostro tema voi immaginate
di parrucconi che si mettono lì a
sfogliare libri realtà l'accademia della
crusca nata intorno un tavolo di
un'osteria nella firenze di fine
cinquecento da quattro letterati
satirici umoristici che volevano ma per
ribellarsi alla pedanteria sono delle
prime ricerche sulla lingua dicevano che
la vera lingua e quella vero fiorentino
che era paradigma dell'italiano è la
lingua dei contadini dei villain e
toscani che celebravano questa cosa fra
grandi bevute allegre chiacchierate con
un con un tono completamente informale
il cazzeggio il cazzeggio la storia
della lingua italiana è nata dal
cassetto il primo vocabolario della
lingua italiana che è stato modello per
i vocabolari di tutte le lingue d'europa
è nato dal cazzeggio e le meglio come le
migliori idee nascono ea nascono appunto
intorno al tavolo cazzeggiando ma cosa
c'entra politicamente corretto che voi
non ci crederete ma anche il
politicamente corretto e nato così
l'espressione è nata da altri
cazzeggiato ri americani negli anni 70
che volevano prendere in giro
l'eccessivo dogmatismo di altri
personaggi di sinistra aveva una cosa
sempre migliori nemici noi ritroviamo al
nostro interno per dire le prime in
america usare il termine politicamente
corretto erano le femministe di un
gruppo chiamato lesbians ex mafia che se
la prendevano con le femministe più
ortodosse che dicevano che import nella
pornografia nel sesso c'è qualcosa di
vietato di proibito allora si sentivano
a dare le politicamente corretto che era
una espressione presa da dai testi di
mauro noda comunque faceva era proprio
una cena una dittatura del pensiero ma
era scherzosa e una provocazione
scherzosa cosa succede negli anni 70
la società americana fa dei grandi passi
avanti
entrano in scena le donne entrano in
scena le minoranze etniche è il
caposaldo della cultura bianca
l'università si apre a queste acquista
questi nuovi apporti è il caposaldo però
il milan sta il caposaldo dell'elite
bianca della cultura bianca
e siccome ci sono degli attriti in
questo con questi nuovi ingressi insomma
delle contestazione della cultura
dominante da parte di queste nuove
minoranze dapprima nei
dei giornali nei magazine comunque gli
intellettuali bianchi comincerò di che
cavani ma qua questo politicamente
corretto ci sta uccidendo
però lo usavano seriamente politicamente
corretto diventa una specie di complotto
ecco si crei una si crea una vera e
propria fake news del politicamente
corretto come progetto della sinistra
per snaturare i veri americani le
tradizioni per sostituirle con un
indistinto di femminismo pietismo e in
questo senso la destra siamo negli anni
di reagan e con tan fine anni ottanta
quei primi anni 90 si comporta come una
minoranza perseguitata perché sta
prevalendo la cultura della vittima gli
antropologi dicono che le comunità si
possono classificare in base a come
reagiscono agli oltraggi c'è la cultura
dell'onore e cioè se viene offeso devi
lavare l'onta col sangue c'è la cultura
della dignità per cui non c'è niente di
male a rivolgersi a un'autorità
superiore per dirimere una controversia
e riguardano insulto insomma denuncia
per calunnia
però nelle quando si tratta di un'offesa
di poco di poco conto dobbiamo essere
superiori lasciamo correre in questo
nuovo tipo di società in cui ci sono
tanti gruppi più o meno su un piano di
parità grazie alle lotte per
l'emancipazione quindi c'è una comunità
asiatica una ghiera le femministe gli
omosessuali e i bianchi ogni attrito
viene vissuto a livello di sopruso e se
si chiede lenzi dell'intervento
dell'autorità per esempio dell'autorità
universitaria per eliminare questo quel
libro considerato
razzista o sessista la destra fa la
stessa cosa se considera una minoranza
discriminata e siccome comunque non è
una minoranza ma negli stati uniti degli
anni 90 ancora il controllo dei giornali
del mondo intellettuale questa bufala
del politicamente corretto persecutorio
prende sempre più corpo perché è molto
molto facile trovare un nemico a cui
dare la colpa rende molto più facile la
vita dall'ambito accademico
l'espressione di entra in politica e
serve a scardinare la fiducia 3a le
classi popolari bianche e chi dovrebbe
rappresentarli di si dice che vedete
quello la sinistra parla complicato non
parla come come mangia invece di
difendere voi lavoratori bianchi
sostiene l'etnia sostiene i neri e noi
in europa
l'abbiamo ricevuta esattamente così è
arrivato da noi il politicamente
corretto in forma come diciamo bufala
persecutoria ci propongono questa idea
del complotto un enorme complotto in cui
la sinistra congiure insieme a
nell'ordine soros i vegani gli islamici
anche il papa che ogni tanto dice
qualcosa di sinistra prova il loro
obiettivo è sterminarono sostituire
tecnicamente l'europa che gli europei
bianchi e cristiani con una
la moltitudine multietnica e
multireligiosa insomma una specie di
oggi tweet letto di oggi con laura
boldrini qual è la differenza tra
boldrini e hitler
nessuna entrambi volevano sterminare
ottenere uniti husain arrivati a questo
punto è col cioè noi di sinistra ci
sentiamo rimproverare il politicamente
corretto da gente che propone il
politicamente scorretto che poi tutto
sommato è un'altra
un'altra un sinonimo di fascismo diciamo
pure e invece cosa facciamo noi di
sinistra ci beviamo questa cosa e
cominciamo a scusarci o pentirci di
essere stati troppo politicamente
provette già questa cosa falsa servono i
primi avercela a proposito è successa la
stessa cosa con radical chic buonismo le
cose che la sinistra in meta come
autocritica per scherzare sui propri
difetti vengono piratati dalla destra e
poi noi i nostri stiletti diventano
clave che poi ci ritroviamo sul groppone
il buonismo era stato inventato da
ernesto galli della loggia un libero per
farlo per criticare prodi e cielo ma
adesso è da una una mamma tacciano su
sulla sinistra in genere e radical chic
l'elegante definizioni ton di tom wolfe
sulla gauche caviar è arrivata ci sono
diventate tutte noi e gli insulti che ci
sentiamo scagliare addosso io stessa ho
lavorato in un giornale di satira cuore
che ha sdoganato in maniera scherzosa e
satirica un linguaggio che adesso quello
normale di giornali come libero come
come la verità
ed è veramente imbarazzante perché da
delle per questo il tema del
politicamente corretto
mi pone veramente dei dubbi morali e
giusto quello quello che faccio sono
stata sono stata anch'io in qualche modo
collaborazionista senza saperlo di
questo di questa deriva
io ricordo che nel 1991 quando lavoravo
a cuore proprio erano le prime i miei
primi anni si parlava di quote rosa e io
ero della della del gruppo che dicevano
quote rosa ma no le donne non sono dei
panda no che non sono dei panda perché
quando un panda viene ucciso nessuno si
si domanda sì ma come era vestito il
panda oppure a ha provocato insomma no
la differenza la differenza cioè a
distanza di tempo io mi pento di avere
di avere
snobbato questa cosa che considerato che
siamo ancora il paese con la
rappresentanza femminile più bassa
d'europa
peggio di noi come in tutto solo la
grecia quando la grecia provvedere a
saremo ben fregati perché non potremmo
più dire peggio di noi solo la grecia e
saremo gli ultimi della classe ecco il
problema è visto che in una sola
settimana sono usciti micromega le
ragioni della sinistra titolo contro il
politicamente corretto e l'espresso
copertina buonisti un cazzo come dire
adesso siamo stati troppo buoni ma
adesso facciamo la faccia feroce
abbiamo letto troppi libri non siamo
stati abbastanza volgari adesso vogliamo
cambiare ed è veramente è tristissimo
perché invece di tenere ferme certe cose
scendiamo a livello dell'avversario
bevendo tutte tutta questa questa questa
affectus che efficacissima peraltro a
livello di marketing che si è che si è
inventato e allora facciamo una cosa
togliamolo di mezzo il politicamente
corretto
chiamiamolo col suo vero nome giustizia
inclusione rispetto per gli altri
ecco si parla di velocità nadia altre
velocità
prendiamoci un attimo in più per
riflettere su come parliamo e su quello
che leggiamo adesso cioè la cultura del
risentimento veicolata dai dai dai
social che se da un lato hanno premesso
delle minoranze di poter esprimere ha
subito la loro voce e partecipare da un
lato hanno una velocità che impedisce la
riflessione su quello che si dice
ecco lato buono
beppe grillo ha paragonato i nostri
politici alle persone affette da autismo
non si sono offesi politici si sono
offesi gli autistici
questa la cosa che è veramente il cambio
di passo e si sono offesi hanno potuto
farlo sentire
dieci anni fa vent'anni fa non sarebbe
stato possibile
però allo stesso tempo se tu esprimi
questo questa critica in forma di
risentimento che oggi è così perseguito
perché quello che ci fa stare insieme
oggi ai miei tempi ridere insieme era
una cosa che tengono insieme una una
classe impartito una categoria oggi e
arrabbiarsi insieme e i social aiutano
molto questa possibilità 9 st di
coagulare il risentimento lo sdegno e
fatti sentire non solo
bisognerebbe trovare altri modi per non
fare sentire la gente la gente sola modi
più più positivi
forse la satira può aiutare
e questo è un altro problema perché per
per esempio criticato per questa battuta
sugli su gli autistici
grillo ha rivendicato il fatto che la
sati all'umorismo non può essere
politicamente corretto e proprio niente
deve essere vietato si deve parlare di
tutto ma quando tu per far ridere ti
servi di una minoranza discriminata per
motivi estranei alla sua volontà
una disabilità un genere un orientamento
sessuale e te ne serve per fare ridere
tu appartieni e tu appartieni alla
all'elite perché sei un maschio bianco
eterosessuale pure ricco e potente
quella non è satira quello è bullismo e
allora io nel mio lavoro devo stare
attenta ad ogni parola per capire dove
dov'è la satira intelligente dove
l'approfittarsi essere proprio dei bulli
perché posso permettermelo ecco spesso
la reazione dal politicamente calda
anticata diciamo così del politicamente
corretto è semplicemente la pigrizia
mentale la poca voglia di cambiare il
proprio linguaggio non accettare che il
mondo sta cambiando e ha bisogno di un
linguaggio diverso
vi ho dei figli adolescenti che ogni
tanto non sono veramente scandalizzati
ma non perché politicamente ha creato
perché le giovani generazioni stanno
crescendo in un mondo in cui certe cose
non si usano più
non ti devi neanche più porre il
problema tu in un certo modo non parli
non usi più epiteti che identificano
qualcuno per le clio per il sesso è un
mondo sfaccettati simo e loro sono già
lì noi siamo un passo indietro se ci
aggrappiamo il nostro vecchio modo di
parlare di pensare con la scusa che con
l'alibi della libertà di parola della
libertà di espressione
siamo soltanto degli ipocriti e non dei
dei politicamente corretti ecco proprio
perché le parole sono importanti
nanni moretti diceva chi pensa chi parla
male pensa male ma chi parla male fa del
male le parole le chiamano adesso atti
linguistici sono atti però perseguiti
attraverso il linguaggio e le nostre
parole possono essere pistole cariche
possono essere di storia salve
c'è una bella differenza tra un'area
un'arma carica che può uccidere con una
pallottola e una invece che va solo boom
però quando sei in una piazza piena di
gente molto vicina una pistola a salve
può fare più morti di una pistola vera
perché crea confusione
pensate solo a quel che è successo a
piazza san carlo a torino poco tempo fa
quindi bisogna stare molto cauti questo
non vuol dire censura o autocensura che
ancora peggio vuol dire senso di
responsabilità per quello che che si
dice e io per prima in quanto scrittrice
in quanto satira in quanto madre sento
per prima questa questa necessità anche
questa ricerca per trovare un nuovo modo
per far ridere senza offendere senza non
a spese dei dei più deboli di chi non ha
avuto voce fino a poco tempo fa è
possibile
sembra la risposta sembra non potremmo
farlo tra cent'anni e una semi una cosa
del futuro quando saremo maturati quando
la società sarà cambiata invece no
perché noi italiani in particolare noi
di una certa età abbiamo avuto la
fortuna di conoscere e di apprezzare
qualcuno che ce l'ha fatta che lo ha
sempre fatto e per tutto il corso della
sua vita sto parlando di dario fo e
franca rame in tutta la loro carriera
hanno sempre fatto satira e umorismo
dalla simpatica dalla parte giusta però
mai ha speso sempre a favore dalla parte
dei più deboli
il palo della coppia perché dario fo
stesso ammetteva che franca rame era la
sua coscienza critica non gli avrebbe
mai permesso di fare battute facili
quasi una un'entità unica di creatività
e allo stesso tempo di consapevolezza di
coscienza politica e devo dire che vi
invito veramente ad andare a riaprire
quei testi o riguardare adesso che si
posso più in su youtube le loro commedie
sono di una come posso dirgli una di una
grandezza di una doppista insuperabile
credo e d'altra parte come gli
accademici della crusca quelli che si
divertivano a ricercare le parole nelle
bocche degli umili stranamente se il
cerchio si chiude perché anche dario fo
e franca rame consideravano la lingua
degli operai dei contadini quella giusta
quella ad ascoltare erano quelle bocche
quelle da ascoltare non quelle dei
professori o degli intellettuali e ecco
mi sembra che il modo più giusto per
chiudere questa conversazione anche
all'insegna la sarebbe facile chiude
all'insegna dell'ottimismo motivazionale
ma c'è una frase dario fo che mi piace
che mi piace molto e proprio quando
siamo nella merda fino al collo che
dobbiamo tenere la testa alta
questa missione alla miglior chiusura il
miglior augurio per tutti noi
[Musica]